dans un monde en évolution permanente où
le changement est l'unique constante
notre faculté d'adaptation est
aujourd'hui plus que jamais primordial
la nature est pour l'homme une
formidable source d'inspiration depuis
toujours
et le règne animal mais plus largement
l'ensemble de la biodiversité
et le véritable témoin vivant des enjeux
et challenges inhérents à notre faculté
à cette faculté d'adaptation des
majestueuses baleines à bosse qui
migrent sur plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres jusqu'au structures sociales
complexes des fourmis
chaque créature recèle une sagesse
unique aujourd'hui je vous propose
d'explorer le parallèle qu'il existe
entre notre capacité d'adapter entre la
capacité d'adaptation de la faune et de
la flore et notre propre développement
donc tout d'abord va aujourd'hui bonsoir
à tous si je suis avec vous ce soir
c'est parce que déjà j'ai réalisé mon
rêve
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui je travaille
en tant que vétérinaire au parc
zoologique de Paris dans le Muséum
d'histoire naturelle et j'ai la chance
de travailler et de m'occuper d'une
grande variété d'animaux sauvages
ces animaux sont pour moi une véritable
source d'inspiration c'est à dire que
j'apprends tous les jours alors que tu
es en travaillant avec eux et pour le
coup c'était quelque chose que je
voulais retransmettre ce soir c'est un
petit peu
l'enseignement que ces animaux
m'apportent
donc quand on s'intéresse au vivant je
préfère parler d'adaptation au pluriel
parce que pour le coup il y a plusieurs
formes d'adaptation
il y a tout d'abord l'adaptation
évolutive
l'adaptation structurelle et
l'adaptation comportementale si on
s'intéresse un petit peu à l'évolution
des êtres vivants
c'est l'adaptation le phénomène
d'adaptation ou adaptation évolutive est
un mécanisme biologique par lequel les
organismes s'adaptent à des changements
dans leur environnement
c'est ce phénomène d'adaptation et la
transmission de l'adaptation au fur et à
mesure des générations qui est la base
de la survie des espèces et de
l'évolution des espèces pour faire
simple lorsque il y a un changement dans
l'environnement les organismes doivent
s'adapter et ceux qui s'adaptent le
mieux ont plus de chances de survivre et
de transmettre ces mêmes adaptations et
donc génération après génération sur le
long terme ça contribue à l'évolution
des espèces
d'un point de vue un petit peu pratique
les adaptations qu'on appelle
structurelles si on prend un individu à
un moment donné sont en fait des
structures physiques anatomiques
physiologiques qui permettent à l'animal
de survivre d'évoluer dans son milieu
pour ça je vais vous prendre un exemple
est-ce que vous connaissez cet animal
alors j'ai entendu plusieurs choses
c'est une pygarde à tête blanche donc
c'est un c'est long c'est l'emblème
justement des États-Unis c'est un rapace
diurne est-ce que vous connaissez
celui-ci je pense que tout le monde là
donc c'est un flamant rose là on a une
autruche ouais de près c'était pas si
facile mais ça va et là un colibri ok
est-ce que vous voyez le point commun
entre ces quatre animaux
voilà ce sont tous des oiseaux et donc à
quel
particularité capacité physique on pense
quand on pense aux oiseaux
voilà on pense à la capacité de voler et
effectivement il y a plus de 10000
espèces qui sont actuellement connues
dans les oiseaux dans le monde il y en a
sûrement bien plus parce qu'on les
connaît pas toutes mais
il
occupent en fait des environnements qui
sont extrêmement variés et est-ce que du
coup toutes les espèces d'oiseaux est-ce
que tous les oiseaux volent
voilà du coup ça ce sont des manchots
effectivement ce n'est pas une espèce
qui est capable de voler parce que pour
le coup en fait ce sont des animaux
marins des oiseaux marins aquatiques
donc qui vont chasser les poissons du
coup à des profondeurs qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 300 mètres et pour le coup en
fait leurs ailes sont adaptées
à l'environnement aquatique et leur chef
de nageoire c'est vachement plus
pratique pour attraper les poissons si
on reprend les exemples précédents et
qu'on prend la pigarette blanche pour le
coup c'est un oiseau qui voit lui avoir
besoin de voler beaucoup plus haut
beaucoup plus longtemps et de planer
notamment en utilisant les courants
ascendants pour repérer ses proies et
potentiellement fondre dessus derrière
et donc en fait les ailes sont adaptées
par leur taille par leur largeur et la
disposition des plumes pour permettre ce
vol si on prend le colibri par contre
c'est une voile qui est beaucoup plus
rapide beaucoup plus précise et ils ont
besoin d'avoir des mouvements très fin
stationnaires qui leur permettent
d'aller chercher le nectar dans les
plantes
et aussi de faire marche arrière quand
ils veulent ressortir les autruches qui
font partie de la famille des ratite
donc on compte les nandous les émeuses
dedans sont des gros c'est une famille
d'oiseaux qui sont tous incapables de
voler ils ont des membres postérieurs
qui sont extrêmement puissants qui leur
servent à courir qui leur servent à
donner des coups de pied pour se
dépendre de leur prédateurs mais en
l'occurrence ils ne peuvent pas voler et
en fait ils ont des ailes qui sont
toutes petites vestigial avec des plumes
qui sont immenses c'est même plume
qu'ils utilisent pour faire une espèce
de parade notamment sur les mâles les
malotruches pendant la période de
reproduction et donc ça je trouve que
c'est un merveilleux exemple de
d'adaptation structurelle parce qu'on a
un même groupe taxonomique donc les
oiseaux qui ont tous des ailes mais par
contre ces ailes sont à chaque fois
adaptées au milieu dans lequel ils
doivent survivre en fait parce que du
coup on a une grosse diversité qui leur
permettent de survivre dans ce milieu là
et ça c'est un phénomène
particulièrement marqué d'adaptation
si on reprend le troisième type
d'adaptation c'est l'adaptation donc
comportementale ça c'est un phénomène
qui est beaucoup plus
qui n'est pas une caractéristique
physique c'est plus une manière dont les
organismes vont s'adapter à leur
environnement et là en l'occurrence je
vais vous prendre l'exemple des orques
donc les orques vous connaissez sûrement
ce sont des grands mammifères marins
donc des cétacés qui sont noirs et blanc
qui peuvent mesurer près de 10 mètres
parfois plus que 10 mètres plusieurs
tonnes qui sont extrêmement puissants
capables de nager très très vite
extrêmement intelligent également et en
fait au sein d'une même espèce on va
avoir plusieurs populations qu'on
appelle des écotypes qui sont
elles-mêmes
ultra spécialisée et en fait qui occupe
du coup des milieux différents et
surtout qui ont des régimes alimentaires
différents donc là je vous ai pris un
exemple du coup avec les populations du
Pacifique Nord donc on a trois écotypes
différents donc il y a les côtes des
orques dites résidentes qui mangent
surtout des poissons et des calamars par
exemple les orques nomades qui elles
vont se nourrir de mammifères marins
donc ça va être des phoques des otaries
et même parfois des baleines on a
également les orques de haute mer qui
elles vivent plus loin des côtes et qui
se nourrissent de requins et en fait ce
que je trouve absolument fascinant c'est
qu'on a donc une même espèce avec alors
des petites différences anatomiques
entre entre chacun parce qu'il y en a
qui sont plus ou moins grandes plus ou
moins trapus mais pour le coup elles ont
les mêmes adaptations structurelles
et en fait elles vont développer des
stratégies qui leur permettent justement
d'attraper les proies dans chacun
chacune leur environnement particulier
si je prends l'exemple des orques
nomades qui mangent comme je vous ai dit
des mammifères marins il y a plein de
vidéos qui existent sur Internet et qui
sont absolument fascinantes de la
manière dont elle vont foncer en fait
sur par exemple un bug de glace un bloc
de glace sur lequel s'est réfugiés un
phoque pour leur échapper et en fait à
plusieurs elles vont créer une énorme
vague qui va submerger et
potentiellement retourner en fait le
bloc de glace ce qui va faire tomber le
foie qu'elles pourront l'attraper
derrière les orcs nomades de haute mer
par contre elle elles ont appris que en
fait les requins lorsqu'on les mettait
sur le dos il rentrait dans un état un
petit peu d'hypnose un état qu'on
appelle l'immobilité tonique et en fait
c'était vachement plus pratique pour les
manger parce que du coup il y a juste à
les mettre sur le dos puis ils arrêtent
de nager ils arrêtent de se débattre et
en fait il meurt d'asphyxie et en fait
c'est assez fou à quel point ils ont
réussi à comprendre et à transmettre
cette connaissance au sein de la
population pour parvenir à chasser des
requins
et ce que je trouve très inspirant c'est
que dans la nature cette adaptation du
coup et trouver des solutions pour
comportementale pour aboutir à leurs
objectifs atteindre leurs objectifs
c'est un combat quotidien c'est à dire
un combat pour leur survie quelque chose
qu'ils ont besoin tout le temps que ça
soit les prédateurs qui s'il n'arrivent
pas à s'adapter n'arrive plus à manger
du coup et donc finiront par mourir ou
les proies qui bah là c'est un peu plus
concret s'ils n'arrivent pas à s'adapter
ils se font ils se font manger et pour
le coup le parallèle que je fais moi
avec notre propre développement
personnel c'est que effectivement pour
accomplir nos objectifs il faut savoir
s'adapter ça c'est clair mais surtout
être capable de travailler au quotidien
et en fait je pense que ce qui est le la
principale leçon c'est
mettre l'effort avec de la discipline
travailler intelligemment exploiter nos
forces et en fait un petit peu comme et
nous en fait moi ça m'inspire
personnellement beaucoup parce que il y
a plein de jours où j'ai pas forcément
envie de me lever je suis fatigué mais
une gazelle par exemple dans la nature
si elle peut pas se permettre d'avoir
une journée off parce que du coup si
elle prend une pause si elle dit non
elle écoute aujourd'hui c'est pas mon
c'est pas ma journée et ben elle se fait
manger et du coup elle a pas le droit à
l'erreur donc dans ces moments-là
quand je suis fatigué quand j'ai pas
envie d'y aller déjà j'essaie de me
rappeler un petit peu quel est mon
objectif et en fait je pense qu'il est
inhérent à chacun moi en l'occurrence
j'ai décidé de dédier ma vie aux animaux
et j'ai envie de tout faire pour que en
fait participer à leur survie alors
bien-être au maximum et en fait je me
dis bah voilà si c'est vraiment ça qui
me donne de la force quand j'ai pas
forcément l'envie d'y aller
[Musique]
et
du coup lorsque
[Musique]
donc je vois vraiment ce parallèle entre
du coup le l'adaptation de la faune
sauvage et cette adaptation qui faut
justement qu'on mette en place nous pour
parvenir à nos objectifs et aujourd'hui
en fait dans le monde actuel on parle
beaucoup d'écologie vous on parle
beaucoup de conscience climatique et en
fait je me voyais pas de parler de
développement personnel sans parler de
conscience environnementale dans le sens
où pour pouvoir s'adapter on a besoin
d'avoir un environnement qui le permette
et c'est pareil pour les animaux du coup
je voulais vous montrer vous parler d'un
exemple que je trouve particulièrement
poignant donc ça c'est une photo du coup
d'une région en Afrique qui montre des
éléphants donc ils font d'Afrique est-ce
que vous voyez quelque chose sur cette
sur cette diapo est-ce que il y a
quelque chose qui vous choque
ils ont pas de défense effectivement
donc pour moi c'est un exemple parfait
d'adaptation c'est à dire que nous
humains avons un impact sur notre
environnement direct et sur notre
environnement de manière générale qui a
un impact sur les animaux qui forcent
les animaux à s'adapter et en
l'occurrence dans cette région il y
avait une guerre civile et une pression
colossale sur les populations
d'éléphants par le braconnage parce
qu'en fait le trafic le commerce en fait
de l'ivoire par le braconnage
extrêmement lucratif et en fait pendant
cette guerre civile il y a près de 90%
de la population des éléphants qui a été
touché par ce braconnage et donc une
pression exercée par les activités
humaines sur cette population qui était
immense et ce qu'on s'est rendu compte
c'est qu'aujourd'hui en fait il y a près
de 51 51% des femelles
âgées de plus de 25 ans donc qui ont
connu la guerre qui n'ont plus de
défense c'est à dire qu'en fait tous les
individus qui avaient des défenses ont
été ciblés par le braconnage et se sont
fait potentiellement tuer et donc celle
qui n'avait pas de défense donc non pas
été prise pour cible donc pas tuer mais
ce que je trouve assez fascinant c'est à
quel point en fait la nature s'est
adapté parce que les femelles du coup
qui n'avaient pas de défense ont eu des
meilleures chances de survivre et en
fait meilleure chance de se reproduire
et aujourd'hui il y a près de 32 % des
femelles qui naissent sans défense donc
ça c'est vraiment cette faculté
d'adaptation évolutive qui est
actuellement en place sous nos yeux et
en fait aujourd'hui on parle des
activités humaines on a cet impact sur
le monde qui nous entoure et
les animaux la biodiversité en fait est
forcé de s'adapter à nous en permanence
et tout comme l'adaptation est une des
clés de leur survie
c'est plutôt le manque d'adaptation ou
l'incapacité à s'adapter qui elle est le
principal la principale menace alors
survie et tout comme c'est la principale
menace à notre développement personnel
quelque part on connaît tous ces gens
qui voilà avaient une idée en tête sont
partis et malgré les les Red Flag et ben
on continue c'est exactement le même
principe et en fait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui par la conscience que l'on a
du coup de l'impact que nous humains
avons sur le monde qui nous entoure et
on fait partie de ce monde donc on a
besoin de le préserver pour préserver
notre propre développement
on a cette responsabilité d'agir
concrètement pour la protection du
climat de l'environnement et à mon sens
c'est quelque chose qui est aujourd'hui
primordial à la fois pour l'ensemble de
la planète mais aussi pour nous en fait
si on veut pouvoir continuer à vivre
dans cette planète donc en conclusion de
cette présentation je dirais que les
facultés d'adaptation du coup des
animaux de la faune sauvage de la
biodiversité sont absolument
considérables et ce sont la clé de leur
survie tout comme ça peut être la clé de
notre développement personnel
développement professionnel ou une des
clés justement de
pour que l'on parvienne à surmonter les
enjeux climatiques et
environnementaux auxquels sont
confrontés nos
sociétés actuelles et je finirai par
dire que il est urgent et il est de
notre responsabilité de protéger toutes
les formes de vie sur Terre merci
beaucoup pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
juste d'un point de vue un peu plus
concret il y a plein d'associations qui
font plein de choses et on a eu des
intervenants qui ont fait des choses
extraordinaires pour le climat là juste
deux mots parce que c'est des gens qui
sont particulièrement importants pour
moi sur un Yvette nature c'est une
association de veto qui a des des
projets de conservation partout dans le
monde et aussi un mot sur waltool c'est
un projet d'un personne grâce à qui je
suis là ce soir et je suis très heureux
d'être avec vous ce soir qui se bat
justement pour récupérer offrir une
belle fin de vie à plein d'animaux donc
merci à eux et voilà il y a une tombola
pour un Yvette si jamais vous avez envie
de d'y participer merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]